thank you
good evening
and welcome to the to this meeting the
development committee I will now read
out the emergency evacuation
announcement
there are no planned fire drills so if
the alarm goes off please leave the
building in under excuse me in an
orderly fashion through the nearest fire
exit
please use either the far exit through
the main doors of the hall or the fire
exit in the storeroom adjacent to the
stage
the far assembly point is the island in
front of the main entrance to the
building
please do not delay your evacuation to
collect any belongings
please do not return to the building
until given permission to do so by
Council staff
please note that the meeting will be
audio recorded
please switch off mobile phones or turn
them to silent
please note that toilet hand washing for
this facilities are in the main foyer
area and I'll make it half past
yeah so we can start mating members
there is a need to use microphones
during the meeting when I invite you to
speak please wait until there is a
microphone in front of you before
speaking as microphones are needed for
the hearing Loop and for the audio
recording these are all switched on and
ready for you to speak so do you do not
need to adjust them
please make sure that the microphone is
directly in front of you before speaking
members voting will be done on a show of
hands in line with the Constitution
I will ask for a show of hands four and
then against recommendations I would
also ask for a show of hands for those
wishing to abstain from voting
okay members
agenda items one or two apologies for
absence substitutes please
there isn't
yeah we've received one for councilor
Tracy Knight no substitution
not okay
a gender item three non-members
attending
nope
agenda item four minutes of the meeting
held on the 20th of September 2022 are
all members in agreement
thank you members I'll consign them
later
agenda item four to receive Declarations
of Interest are there any Declarations
of Interest
cancel the meal
can
just a moment
gri was ordered On The Board of Trustees
of pinchfield when it was planned to
uh ex to uh all to the car parking
Arrangements there
[Music]
high on that we're okay thank you very
much but thank you for bringing that to
our attention
a gentum item six 22 stroke zero zero
six seven three full
ready sports and social club London Road
ready Katie Fowler will present the
officer's report thank you Katie
that one
now
yeah can you hear it no it's not
it's not no I couldn't hear me
hello
try that
hello hello
yeah there we go that's it thank you
so Rayleigh sports and social club the
application site is located within the
scr1 allocation is located on the north
of London Road and to the south of The
Wider residential development of Aussie
Park and with the aerial photograph that
you can see on the screen this is the
policy SEO one that's been carried out
known as Wallace at Woolsey Park and
then you have London Road along the
south of the site and the application
sites this green parcel here and I'll
just scroll down and you can see
it's more zoomed in so you have really
sports and social club here and then the
building subject to the application are
just located south of that and London
Road here the site is also north of the
BP garage which is here and then the
development which is known as land
adjacent Grange villa which is currently
being developed out for residential
purposes just here as well
the application seeks to retain the
erection of seven Porter cabins and the
use of the site for educational purposes
the application is therefore
retrospective in nature the school
specializes in providing educational
needs for children with social emotional
and mental health and autism spectrum
disorders
if I just go onto the layout
I've just been asked if you could sorry
uh Council Albany okay
thank you uh Cancer sign is asked if you
can speak up a little bit please thank
you
sorry let me get the plan up then
so the school comprises six General
teaching rooms one office a medical room
changing facilities main hall and dining
area which is included within the
clubhouse Administration and sports
spaces storage lockers are maintenance
stores
the proposed use of the site would
operate from 7am to 5 PM Monday to
Thursday and 7 A.M to 12 30 on Fridays
outside of these hours the primary use
of the site for outdoor sports and
recreation purposes would remain the
default use the school currently has 18
pupils aged 12 to 16 with the ability to
educate up to 30 pupils the school was
25 staff on site and six off-site
and so this application on screen you
can see Rayleigh sports and social club
at the existing buildings here and then
these are the porter cabins that have
been brought onto the site for the use
the applicant has expressed that
Corelli's Crowley's Foundation has a
focus on health and Sport and the
location of the school within Rayleigh
sports and social club was sequentially
chosen on this basis
it is important for the children to be
in a location which has open outdoor
corridors so the school does not feel or
appear as a mainstream School the
planning statements submitted with the
application discusses at paragraph 6.4
that the open space around the school is
distinctly different to mainstream
schooling which benefits the pupils this
has been taken into account during the
consideration of the application if I
just move on to the layout plan which
shows The Wider site hopefully you can
all see that on the screen but
um to the is to the site you see radio
sports and social club and the school
water cabins and then you see the wider
playing pictures and playing field
the application site is located in the
policy scr1 which is allocated for
residential development there is
commonly no evidence before the LPA
which would suggest that RDC as the loan
toner are intended on developing out the
site which is supported by the 28-year
lease signed in 2020.
in addition the number of units required
by policy SEO one have been met
elsewhere within the allocation site and
the requirement for play Space public
open space and sports pitch provision
has also been provided Elsewhere on site
nevertheless the proposal would not
preclude future development of the site
for housing as attended by policy SC R1
at a future date
section 37 of the Town and Country
planning act states that in dealing with
an application for planning permission
the LPA shall have regard to the
development plan so far as it is
material to the application as well as
any other material considerations
it is considered that although the
proposal would fall contrary to its
allocation within policy scr1 the
development is acceptable taken into
account the other material
considerations discussed
the application site is well contained
from wider views of the surrounding area
the proposed development be clustered to
the south of the clubhouse avoiding
spool over a larger area the development
would be modest in scale and would have
a limited impact upon the wider area for
these reasons
a 2.4 meter boundary fence has been
installed along the perimeter of the
school and ball stopped Benson and
nesting lands about in the playing
fields so the fencing extends up to
around where the pond is and then the
rest of the site is
um met with the ball stop fencing
dense vegetation along the boundary
would be largely maintained and
therefore the development would not be
visible but would not be overly visible
from the public realm the development is
not considered to have a detrimental
impact upon the appearance of the site
or the character of the area and would
be compliant with policy dm1 in this
regard
there are currently no occupied
adjoining Residential Properties
nevertheless even once policy SEO 1 and
land adjacent Grange Villa to the South
are built out the impact of the
development would be considered
relatively limited if I just go back to
the
a little photograph so you can see that
the scr1 of Woolsey Park does extend
fairly near to the perimeter of really
sports and social club and you can see
the starting of the carrying out of the
large adjacent Grange Villas
nevertheless the buildings are located
here and so there would be a sufficient
distance from Wolsey Park and also would
never would not be directly within the
sight line of the residential
development of land adjacent Grangeville
because of the BP Garage in front of
that
there would not be an impact
though sorry
there would not be an unreasonable
degree of overlooking that would occur
due to the boundary treatments dense
vegetation and separation with any
future nearby residential development
though noise during recreational hours
may be apparent to nearby Residential
Properties given the small number of
students on site it is not considered
that noise levels would be unreasonable
for the nearby residential context
in addition no neighbor comments in
relation to noise or disturbance from
the school have been received and given
the retrospective nature of the
application it is likely that these
would have come forward either as
objections to the application or to the
Environmental Health Department
it's considered that the proposal would
not have a significant detrimental
impact upon residential amenity and the
proposal would be compliant with policy
dm1
just going to move to the site layout so
you can see the context of the parking
so the apoa parking standard is required
education facilities to provide one
parking space per 15 students for staff
the school would have the capacity for
up to 30 pupils and therefore by these
standards would require two parking
spaces
all pupils are dropped off or get the
bus or school minibus to the site and
only teaching staff drive it has been
clarified within the planning statement
that school and sports club would
operate at different times meaning there
would not be an anticipated conflict in
the use of this car park
however it is clear from the information
from the information submitted that
there are far more staff on site then
seen at mainstream School
the planning statement outlines that
there are 25 staff on site the submitted
plan details that there are 25 spaces on
site and therefore the site would be
capable of providing sufficient parking
for the school staff
a travel plan was also submitted with
the application which sought to
encourage staff to look for more
suitable means of travel where possible
and to reduce the number of single
occupancy car Journeys
in light of this S6 County Council is a
local author Highway Authority have not
objected to the application and that
this also includes the use of the
existing access of London Road sorry you
can't actually see on that plan but if I
go to here
well that one but the existing access
which is just along the south of about
South Boundary down here that's an
existing access that radio sports and
social club use
and so on this basis it's considered
that the scheme would not conflict with
transport and Highway Safety
the application site is located adjacent
to a wooden area which is subject to TPO
the council's arboricultural officer did
raise initial concern to the scheme due
to the concern that there was tarmacking
of the car parking spaces however the
agent was able to demonstrate that this
tarmac is historic and the council's
officer was content that no further
impact assessment was required there is
also a pond on the southern boundary
which is you can see on this plan here
um however it is not considered that an
ecological appraisal would be required
as any harm that would have occurred
during construction would have already
occurred and would be a matter of
separate legislation
both national and local policies seek to
retain playing pitches an outline that
developed development should resist the
loss of existing playing pitches
exception 3 a sport England's Playing
Fields policy and guidance outlines that
sport England will oppose the loss of
Playing Fields except where the
development affects only land incapable
of forming playing pictures it is clear
from the submitted plans that no pitch
loss would occur as a result of the
development and the school has been
cited in an area which is prone to being
waterlogged and could not be used as a
pitch provision or training area on this
basis but just show you the existing and
proposed plans so this is the existing
plan prior to the school being taken
place so you can see the two playing
pitches here and then
with the school in place there are
actually now four playing pictures
education would have use of One Mini
football pitch on site for educational
needs it is understood that the school
have improved the maintenance program at
the pitches as well as having improved
the club facilities and that is
recognized by the increase of playing
pictures on the site
taking these factors into account sport
England have not objected in principle
to the development however there were
concerns raised from ECB and Essex
cricket by sport England regarding pitch
maintenance during the week
whilst the school finished at 12 30 on a
Friday to allow for the pictures to be
maintained a typical qriket Square
requires at least 20 hours of
Maintenance a week and this was
therefore insufficient
as a result a pitch net maintenance plan
has been prepared by the applicant and
agent the maintenance plan provides the
basis for access to the site during
school opening hours to maintain the
sport pictures
the plan has been prepared in
consultation with Fairview Cricket Club
and the ECB to establish their
requirements sport England have reviewed
the maintenance plan with the cricket
and football governing boards and have
advised that no objection is raised to
the application subject to the
imposition of the maintenance plan by
condition
the application is therefore recommended
for approval chairman subject to the
conditions that are out in the report
and the amendment to condition 2 as
outlined within the addendum thank you
one speaker on this
Mr David
grayling
creating thank you
um you hope we'll have we've got a seat
there for you please
you have five minutes and then uh when
four minutes are up you've got one more
minute of unfunctional interruptions so
you've got one minute okay you don't
want to time it and that's fine no no
I've got um I've got two people timing
it for you thank you
that's on so you just can everyone hear
me oh oh yeah definitely is that okay
okay perfect so
yeah so hello um my name is David
Crowley and just before I start I just
like to thank the committee for taking
the time to listen to me
um
so as I said my name is David quailing
I'm the secretary education uh approved
proprietor of Christ education limited
which is an independent special school
for children with social emotional
mental health needs and autism spectrum
disorder and we're a special pools
catering for the needs of
18 children 12 to 16 year olds they are
boys it's a specific boys school and the
school always seeks to address the
demand for Education locally and
nationally in the future
the school is Department of Education
approved it's officer regulated and we
adhere to the education acts in terms of
of England
the school is funded for its children by
local authorities so local Authority
children from Essex County Council and
South End majority of from Essex County
Council and the children that we cater
for are children that have no access to
education they have educational health
care plans they're in statutory
assessment most of our children are
rathering care foster or in Care Homes
permanently
the nature of the school
um addresses the needs for its Mission
so every young child has a opportunity
by law to have a first education and at
the moment these children often
disenfranchised backgrounds and
societies and family support is is not
there so School becomes a social place
for these children some of the children
that access the school have not attended
school for several years there is no
place not in Essex or nationally for
these children
um our values are grounded on a
determination to change an education
landscape and we start we want to start
this first of all we watch it
the ambition for the school and his
objective is to provide education for
the heart to reach young people and the
curriculum that we that we adhere to is
a national curriculum it's not National
curriculum in mainstream schools and
it's designed for that purpose it's to
engage children back into education and
give them a consistent approach through
their years 7 8 9 10 and 11.
the provision is already proven to be a
success
um nature of the application is
retrospective and we have had a number
of children leave the school in year 11
already and those children have
absolutely and I butt the trend and out
of the children that have left they've
gone into apprenticeships and full-time
education that's every single child
that's left us in year 11 has had a
positive destination
which we're really proud of
the nature of the school buildings was
um alluded to by Katie by Design the
school it doesn't have corridors it
doesn't have stairs
the school was designed based on the
needs of the children and how they can
be safe in the community that they are
every day so it is by design it looks
nothing like a school
open space is key
um the quick limb is a therapy first
quick followed by Sports base curriculum
and then we follow that with a formal
education
so in the type of provision that we
deliver is what we call Montessori
learning learning through play
um and Montessori as of in key success
and I know the children are an asset to
the school as we move forward really
there has been a number of benefits to
the valley town sports and social club
for the provision of the school being
there when the site's not open at
weekends the sorts Boston Social Club
over there and some evenings the school
is there from Seven a in the morning to
sort of four or five o'clock in the
evening except for on a Friday afternoon
where
unable to have a habitation with the
Sportsman Social Club we've been able to
invest in the facilities and that's not
just the education facilities but it's
the change rooms it's the sports and
social club one minute to go okay
perfect and and we're also addressing
locally where we are delivering
provision for things called activate in
the holidays and extra curriculum where
we're addressing holiday hunger also
um so our school staff are doing extra
curriculum during outside of school
hours
in relation to the consultation
principle England I support this
application which we're really pleased
with we're adding value there
um and for me it's about providing
facilities and an environment for
children and
um I suppose I need to conclude that um
that may just consider that this
application is is favorable for the
things that have been mentioned in the
application process
and I'd like to thank Katie for how
she's managed the planning application
at this point and I'm sure Katie will be
able to respond to any questions
ideally I'd love to go into school
tomorrow and to confirm to the staff and
children that we have a future at rally
Town sports and social club for the
foreseeable future and thanks for your
time thank you very much before I ask
members invite members to speak I've got
a non-pecuniary interest that I am and
Essex County councilor
can I have that 90 please
thank you very much we can't actually
ask you any questions yeah you can go
back with your friends
thank you
I'm going to be visiting board members
um
we have councilor Jim Crips counselor
Chris Stanley of the are the world
members who would you like to speak
yes over to you
uh like you bear with me for a few
minutes while I
preload my question for the
officers a bit of context
when I started reading the high level
introduction to the proposal it read a
bit
like uh future tense and I was under the
impression initially that cabins had to
be erected and so on and so on when I
got to the officers report clearly it
was in the
past tense
so I felt like to just contact the
officers and make sure I'd got it right
which I did and I'll share with the
members
um the officers have confirmed that
um the facilities are already pre-built
and this is in fact a retrospective
application
I also was advised that the
recommendation albeit Porter gab in
style and I understand the need for a
low-level type of environment for its
purpose but the officers have confirmed
that they're looking for full planning
permission despite the poorly carbon
nature of the buildings
in
the officer's report 2.3 it also made
passing reference to
some lease issues that need to be
resolved
the planning officer has reiterated that
these matters are legal matters not
planning criteria
the officers couldn't answer any further
reference para number 3.9
um they couldn't answer this any further
than they already have and that's
because the RDC asset management team
have not responded on the ser-1 policy
intentions
this means the officers have had to make
an assumption for their conclusion that
follows later in the uh in the paper
effectively they're assuming that the
recently renewed lease which is about 26
years to run I believe is the way
forward and that's what will happen
another point they couldn't take any
further was reference power 4.6
where conversely what's the district
council Asset Management did make a
comment and it was a note of caution on
a lease issue
which appears to be left hanging in the
air there's no conclusion to that
suggestion that it needs to be kept that
was the inference I took from it
so
overall my take on this and I have to
say
I think it's a positive thing to be
applauded given the mental health
direction we seem to be heading in in
general these days
um
it seems to me that the school concept
was already approved by the first
application
and obviously it does provide a very
useful service
although what we're seeing now is a
little bit of limitation on access
grouping in which is what's defined in
condition number two so there's a degree
of limit for public assets obviously
because of the score
but overall I applaud what they're doing
however in the interest of all the
parties concerned what I don't see is a
clear definition of roles and
responsibilities
for two parties
sharing long-term
a council asset
which leads me
to my question because if it is 26 years
of color habitation there's clearly
going to be issues that come up
and I think it will benefit all three
parties the owner the Lee c and the
third party if there was a clear mandate
there which I don't know where there is
or there isn't I don't even know where
the officers know that so my question to
the officers might be unfair are we
aware that the new lease includes
definition for Alicia and a third party
sharing
which goes back to a couple of points
above on legal matters that are
outstanding feels to me given
the application
has these facilities already that we
should be trying to tidy up these what
are in-house issues most of them
from a legal point of view and I only
say it on the basis that it protects all
three parties going forward
because in 26 years things could get
difficult shall we say we might even be
facing more
retrospective planning applications and
so on so I think
that's your point have the officers any
knowledge of the new lease and Does it
include both of autism thank you Council
Crips I've just passed a note to uh Phil
and he's going to answer that part for
you okay thank you
thanks thank you chair and thank you
councilor Crips for raising those issues
because I think they're important to
consider and what I would say though and
I will provide a bit more of a response
as to how we might consider them more
broadly but it's quite important that
the development committee understands
the difference in roles that we have as
part of the local planning Authority
making a decision Phil excuse me speak
up a bit please sorry as part of
so I swallow it
the local planning Authority we need to
make a decision on what is in front of
us from a development point of view as
to whether that's appropriate within the
confounds of planning policy and
legislation the rest of it so I think
councilor Chris you raise important
questions around the lease Arrangements
but those are not questions that we can
consider as part of this development
proposal
so what I would suggest is that offline
and as part of any other Council
committee that would be relevant to talk
about Assets in particular and the way
in which facilitation of the school on
site for instance could be allowed in
the longer term as part of the
allocation or Alternatives explored
which clearly is something that would
need to be considered if this
application were to gain approval that
that's the route by which we would need
to consider those issues but this
evening members I think it's important
just to note that the lease arrangements
and the legal Arrangements around
whatever has happened and whoever has a
lease with who and whatever length of
time that is for is not relevant to the
decision that we're making about the
location of the school buildings and the
appropriateness of the school buildings
being there so that's deliberately why
Katie and the officers report is vague
on that point because we're saying that
I think the key Things Are
the lease is not to be considered as
part of this
um the allocation of the land in terms
of future development is the key thing
for us as planning authority to think
about rather than necessarily the lease
Arrangement so it is relevant to think
about what the long-term allocation for
the land might be and therefore whether
this is appropriate within that context
but the report is clear that it is
appropriate on the basis that at the
moment there is no other proposal for
development of the site and subject to
the decision that you make this evening
as the local planning Authority that we
make
um
that will then potentially need to be
considered in the longer term as to what
the council may want to do with the site
in accordance with that allocation
I hope that that's clear I've tried to
provide a little bit more information
than just saying you can't consider the
lease Arrangements yes of course
yeah I did anticipate that sort of
logic coming forward actually
um what I'm interested though because I
do believe these issues I've raised
are important for the for the applicant
as well given he wants and he's
come forward in his uh proposal he's
made it quite clear that he wants
permanence in the future as well so I
think it is in his interest to know what
his roles and responsibilities and
rights are in that context and if it's
not in the lease or any other document
it should be in my opinion so what how
do we move to a box where that gets
addressed if we don't do it in planning
yeah thanks Council creates I think I
think in the planning context what we
would be deciding if um if the the
committee makes the decision to go with
the recommendation for approval is that
this development is appropriate and
therefore in planning terms it's
appropriate subjects to conditions and
and the standard things that we would be
looking to to achieve
any development anywhere has to have
planning permission for it to be
considered appropriate but any landowner
or leaseholder will need to have legal
arrangements as to whether they can
remain on site so I think it's about
separating that process here where the
local planning Authority is making a
decision based on what is appropriate in
planning terms and the council as a
landowner needs to make a decision as to
what is appropriate on its site as to
what it wants to do with the land and
who should be on the land and what they
should be operating for instance in
terms of the school's operation
long-term operation long-term plans
whether that changes in time things may
change and therefore that's where lease
and legal agreements change but the
planning process is separate from that I
hope that helps
perhaps we could take it this further
offline as Phil was uh maintained if
that's okay and then we can move on to
other counselors yes
um that's fine I do get Phil's point but
what I do don't want to happen is the
subjects to evaporate no we don't feel
good and I would like to be involved in
that process
um because I brought the issues up I'd
like to follow it through well let's uh
as you're a wall council with um is it
councilor Newport and Council Stanley I
am sure well I know you will be invited
to any meeting that is going to be held
okay okay I won't be involved
but I don't need to be but the more
counselors certainly do okay okay thank
you meeting is to be taken offline is
that okay Phil thank you uh I've got
Chris Stanley Adrian Eaves Ian Foster
and you're the next Ward counselor thank
you chairman again you've got five
minutes okay okay um as we all know this
uh parcel land was given despite the the
Gunn family to help with the activities
of young people in the area to the
council back in those days
um I from what I can understand is that
it is now no longer available to our
young people
um perhaps the officers could identify
how our young people are going to use
this parcel of land in Recreation
purposes
um it was as as I say the gum family
when they released this land to the
council it was for everyone's use
especially youngsters and it seems to me
at this moment in time it's now
non-existent to our young people is this
true thank you Council Katie would you
like to come back please
thank you chairman um so
in terms of its availability so the
school is operating in hours where the
site was not being used so it's actually
providing a function that when prior to
it
s presence on the site the site was
absent of any in any activity so
it isn't changing the
use outside of that's of the school and
how people used radio sports and social
club that in itself isn't changing and
that's why they've done the management
plan so that it does allow for those
uses to continue in association with the
school on site and my understanding is
that prior to the school being on the
site there wasn't this kind of open
space Park thing that meant that anybody
could go and use the site whenever
anyway because there are Gates which
would be shot and locked and things like
that and um this site is very secure in
that way so it was only being used in
perhaps in the evenings but primarily at
the weekend when there were games and
things like that so the scores actually
provided the use kind of during the week
and that's why the hours are slightly
different on the Friday as well so that
the radio sports and social club can
continue to function uh within the
afternoon so the school have adapted
around
ready sports and social club to ensure
they can continue on site and just
basically filling hours that hadn't have
got any use prior to the being on the
site
does this mean that the Roadie turned
and sports and social club is now
non-existent for players to play
football at weekends or is it still
available
it's still available so yeah that's why
so that's part of the management plan
was so that they could maintain the
pitches in the week so that at the
weekends the pictures could definitely
be used by players and my other question
I want to ask you is that is it
considered that there is enough parking
spaces for that I mean you've got three
you've got three pitches there which
will hold something like 200 200
uh people including players parents and
whatever you or
to look after that many
on on the site or is it only one pitch
at a time will be used
so that's not part and parcel of this
application so this application we can
only consider the parking spaces in
relation to the school the parking users
really sports and social club would have
been considered at a time when they had
either gained planning permission I know
a few years ago there was permission for
the car parking spaces on the site so
I'd take it that they would have
considered that at that time but in this
application we can only consider it in
relation to the school and there would
be sufficient parking for the school
okay thank you place
future
um could I suggest that what I was going
to say would be more relevant up could I
suggest that what I was going to say
would be more relevant after the vote
as I discussed with you earlier it's
just something I want to highlight which
is on this issue would that be
okay
once we've done the boat that's it so
I'm just uh
it's not it's not on the application but
it is relevant to this particular
Enterprise I say
I just want to just want clarification
from you cancer Reeves is that I mean if
it's a matter that's not part of the
decision-making process tonight then we
can take it offline uh I have taken it
offline with you I just want to it's not
it's nothing other than uh bringing
information to the committee for future
so it's just this particular application
is relevant to you I don't know if you
remember I spoke to you about special
schools
um uh allocation some little while ago
with regards to s106 agreements yeah yes
and it's that right okay so it's just
bringing it to bring it to people's
names so nothing that you're going to
say needs to have any bearing on the
relevance of the decision being made
tonight no and I don't want to influence
either okay
so can that be uh it would just be a
statement right so you can do a
statement yeah okay okay
some of my stuff's been picked up
already but I've still got some
questions
um first of all in the paragraph 2.3
page 6.3 the application is described as
retrospective is it only covering what's
already in place or is there anything
additional included in it
so I'll ask all my questions before you
get to the answer so
please thank you
um
this Mr drain has alluded to the lease
not been relevant to the discussion but
informationally I'd be interested to
know is the lease between Rayleigh
sports and social club and the school or
is it between
Russian District Council on the school
just asking for information
and also how long is the lease as a
matter of Interest with the school
um
I'd just like to go on briefly
um
in paragraph 3.11 page 6.4 it states
it's considered that although the
proposal would fall contrary to policy
scr1
due to reasons as outlined above the
development is considered acceptable in
principle
then goes on to say in paragraph 3.9
it says it would not preclude future
development of the site for housing as
attended I think it meant intended by
policy ser-1 at a future date
so my question around that is has the
asset management under Council Crips
touch upon it as the asset management
team or the planning policy team giving
them the indication of the likelihood of
scr1 being needed for future Housing
Development
and my final question is if
approval were granted this evening
could it be granted as a temporary
consent for a fixed period of time
thank you councilman Katie or Elon would
you like to pick up the
job yeah that's fine
that's
fine
sorry let's just write a menu
um so yes in terms of what's on site
that is what's present and what is
proposed so there's not at the moment
there is no additional board cabins or
additional facilities proposed it's as
according to the plan and that is what's
present
um I'll leave Phil to pick up on the the
lease question I'll just cover the other
questions first so
um the asset management team hasn't
commented in relation to the scr1 policy
they've only commented in relation to
the lease and planning policy and not in
discussion or haven't brought anything
to light about the scr1 being brought
forward
um in terms of this site at present
um and oh and sorry in terms of whether
it would be needed as well that was part
of why we've considered that although it
doesn't fall in compliance incomplete
compliance with policy se1 is still
acceptable because we are we are meeting
our five-year housing Supply and the
policy SEO one was allocated for a set
number of houses and that has already
been met on the site within the parcels
so although when it was allocated it was
expected to have to use policy sr1 as a
whole I just pull up scr1
so you can see it on the screen and it
was expected that the whole parcel was
going to have to be used to to
fulfill that allocation however it has
been already met by The Phases that have
been granted planning permission at
present
um and in terms of the temporary
permission I don't did you want to cover
that
sorry thank you chair thank you Council
Foster we'll um dance around some of
these questions between officers if you
don't mind but um I just add to what
cases just said it's absolutely correct
but of course what we most we must
remember that the allocations within the
local plan scr1 and other sites there's
a minimum housing Target that's kind of
trying to be achieved so whilst that's
true from a five-year housing Supply
point of view the site's still and and
in terms of the level of development
that's proposed on the site the site
still could come forward in some form in
the future and so I think that that's
why that there's an ability to think
about this as we go forward in any
potential future applications come
forward to essentially develop out that
allocation in the longer term on the
lease Point uh again I'm sure that there
are those in the room who could answer
that question but I
I don't know for sure completely who the
lease is with I believe it's sublet
um with the the sports club but the
point is is that it's not really
relevant to the decision that we're
making so we could find out that
information and have that discussion and
I think that discussion should be had
from an asset's point of view and what
the council wants to do with the site in
the longer term uh as for who it's with
and the actual legalities of it and the
detail and the length um I I don't know
the full answers so it would be wrong
for me to assume and give you
information that might be incorrect
um we'll come on to your question about
temporary permission uh I'll let you do
that one
so as the report sets out uh as Katie's
written in her report I mean the the
actual proposal is considered acceptable
um however if
members were mindful of the allocation
for residential development and on that
basis were more comfortable with
granting a temporary consent that is
possible
but what you have to bear in mind and
what the committee will have to bear in
mind is what level length of time that
temporary consent
would be for because
we have to be reasonable because what
we're saying is is that the development
is acceptable and you can't give a
temporary consent to an applicant that
immediately puts them in a position
where they've got to either start
thinking about the expense of
reapplying to extend that consent or
they've got to start seeking alternative
locations
so it is possible but there needs to be
some consideration that that length of
temporary consent needs to be reasonable
could I come back on that chairman if
that's all right yes Council after he
would like to say something just um it's
a slight expansion on the same subject
but
where where it feels like it's going
given the comments you that you just
made one is that
the lease almost would override a
development a decision by the council to
want to develop it
is that it's just a statement or
yeah is that a question or a statement
well I'll make it as a question would
Elise without some um some limit put on
it
override the council's ability to decide
to go ahead with development on that on
the land
perhaps if I come back on that
um I think we'd probably need a legal
view as to exactly what the restrictions
would be but perhaps if we think about
this a bit more hypothetically
um I know we've had this discussion
separately with different councilors but
the the principle here is is that
planning permission an application can
be made for
any piece of land any applicant
regardless of whether they own the land
regardless of whether they have the
legal ability for a release or any other
arrangement to actually deliver the
development it can the the planning
system allows for anyone to apply for
anything
um and so I think the answer to the
question is we could make a decision
here as the local planning Authority
that the development were acceptable in
terms of what the recommendation says
but if there is no legal agreement lease
or otherwise in place for that person
operator to run a facility in this
situation then it it can't exist so the
legal framework whereby a landowner
needs to give permission for someone to
do something on the land or any anywhere
anywhere else that would override the
planning permission the planning
permission is just saying that it's
appropriate in planning terms you'd
still need to have legal Frameworks
agreements to actually do the
development on site if that makes sense
okay
I can't Swifty
chairman
hear me thank you
right I'm
a little bit of concerns councilor
Foster mentioned SE R1 and the pain
application is based on a
um with the football pitches and
everything else that's there
now
this is a retrospective plan permissions
everything is there at the moment and it
works and if great outcomes applauding
for that but in the future if seir one
is built out won't those pitches and
things disappear and make what the
school does sort of
irrelevant because they won't be able to
do what they're doing now to get such
great outcomes
so maybe looking at a temporary
play an application on this one I think
might be a good idea because it might
change in the future
so there's some idea on that
so maybe I don't know what would be
acceptable of my three year site like
that
okay I'll put okay I'll put a motion
that we Grant a temporary planning for
three years on this application
I'll second it
second that
oh yeah
my members we've got a motion on the
table
with a condition
of a poet for three years
can I have a vote that we will accept
this motion
please
and then we'll debate it
six
six
against
not right members that's
six four
four against two is four against thank
you
so we'll do uh if we
can't get my words out today members
will debate this if needed if not we'll
go through the full vote for approval
anyone
can you get I can't hear you can't hear
a word you'll say no it's not on can you
hear me now no no
yes
coming through yeah
um I had a concern with the development
in the fact that
um they've already put the buildings in
and then asked for retro perspective
planning permission my concern is if the
school is successful and in that case
I'm quite happy for it to go ahead
um on that basis but I'm concerned that
if the school is successful they'll want
to they'll just add more buildings and I
would like to put a condition on it that
they do not put any more buildings on
without coming back for extra planning
permission and they don't try to do it
as a retrospective again so we could do
is that something you can put on as a
condition could we do that through the
motion it sorry it wouldn't really be a
reasonable condition because in any
respect the school would require plan
admission to put more buildings or there
would be mid development or something
but the they would require a plan of
mission so it wouldn't really be a
reasonable condition on the basis that
it is already covered by planning
legislation and I appreciate that in
this instance it is retrospective and I
appreciate your concern with the
potential for that to continue however
if we have to look at the condition and
apply that with the conditions tests I
would be concerned that that wouldn't be
met on the basis that it would require
Planning Commission anyway
Katie could we uh can I come in there
sorry yeah could we not put the
condition on that no other
structures go on it until they come in
for uh if it's required
because they're not just they have to do
planning information forward that we
don't get into this situation again
we've got retrospective so what we could
do is look at a condition surrounding
the permitted development I'm not sure
entirely how permit to them would apply
for a school in this basis obviously
with a mainstream school that's a bit
clearer however we could look at
removing the permitted development
rights for educational purposes so that
would ensure that an application would
have to come forward and they wouldn't
have that those rights right so okay uh
oh
the motion was for three years and that
was carried yes yes okay six four
they want to offer them
you you need a mic well one next to you
oh looked they come like they're like
buses two at a time
Mr chairman um
just to get this absolutely
um
correct we are now voting for or we will
be voting for a three-year term is that
correct yes
I think that's really unfair for the
school I don't see how they can possibly
pay a plan for the future or on just
having three years therefore I wouldn't
support this vote thank you okay thank
you
we've already discussed this matter
um at length and it's been asked umpteen
times over what the legal situation is
if the legal situation is clarified then
I think this motion will the purpose of
this motion will just go away
uh I think that this is preempting I
agree with uh
what's been said previously I think this
is unfair on the school and I think that
we are preempting what the legal
position is by doing this and I would be
against actually putting this uh
condition in place thank you thank you
yes the allocation not the least
um Council Lawman
thank you chairman I agree with with
everything that's been said about this
so-called three years I think it's
unfair to put this sort of as pressure
if you like on a school for three years
I mean what is the future in this I mean
if they've got a progressive training
program in three years time where are
they going to be I understood at the
beginning we talked about 26 years and
and there we have it and I just don't
understand all this other talk I
understand the reasoning but we had all
this put forward to but the officer and
I'm quite content personally
to approve the original application yes
but that's not what we've got what I
understand now I want you to know My
Views and I cannot support the
three-year thing yeah
absolutely can I just come back
um
it could be much more sensible under the
situation to propose a deferment I
realized that we've got to vote on the
motion that's on table first but I'd
like to propose subject to whatever the
vote is that we defer for Clarity on the
legal side of things because that seems
to be coming quite a block right I've
just been notified that uh Phil wants to
speak to clarify something
I imagine Council FD May well come back
and say something similar my
understanding from the motion the reason
for the motion is to do with the fact
that the site is allocated for Housing
Development this is nothing to do with
the lease Arrangements because as I've
already said the lease Arrangements
cannot have anything to do with the
decision that we're making here tonight
regardless of whether there's a 26 year
lease or 126-year lease or whatever it's
irrelevant to the decision that we're
making so again my understanding and
chair I'm sure you're about to confirm
and vice chair is that the motion is on
the basis of the allocation and
understanding what may come forward in
the future with regard to the allocation
not the lease Arrangements
councilor empty would you like to
clarify what you said in your motion
please
okay I just was going to say this is
about the education nothing to do with
the lease I'm worried about the training
Fields going away and that's the whole
point of that's what the school does
well using the training Fields that's
why I'm worried about but my motion is
that we go through a temporary
permission for three years with the
school
when that was seconded by councilor
Stanley then let's have a motion on the
table
for approval with the temporary three
years allocation
sorry Avon
the conditions there would be condition
relating to any future permitted
development yes with the permitted about
three years yeah definitely
so we've got that members for approval
can I have a show of hands please
oh sorry okay
would you mind clarifying the last vote
of what it was for please we had to do a
vote because motion on the table once
you have a motion on the table you have
to vote that the members will accept
that motion that's what we voted for
that we would then debate and this is
what we're doing we weren't voting for
approval we so we have any committee
then we have a motion on the table you
have to vote to say you will agree to
debate the motion or disagree
we agreed six four and that's what we've
done and now
we're going to the vote to say approval
with the condition
information developments that's what
we're going through thank you chairman
okay thank you Jim that's the best I can
clarify it uh the office
if they need to they will uh correct me
if needed
yeah
okay members
so we're now voting for the motion
with the condition
for all members in favor please please
have a show of hands
against
same generation
four four I'm six against so members we
go back to the original
uh approval
so we
the recommendation is for approval kind
of members can have
yeah we've got
um
lost it
there it is
so we've got approval subject to item on
number two you hope you've all read it
thank you
yeah right so as long as you've read
that that's fine
still do it it's just about approving it
from an on a permanent basis rather than
the temperature right members
thank you chairman is there a condition
on this uh recommendation that there
cannot be any further development on the
site
yeah
yes there is there is okay just for
clarification
application members four please put your
hands up
against
any of sanctions
one oh sorry
sorry
you've lost weight I couldn't see you
with the mic
that members that has carried
nine
four two extensions thank you members
hi stories would you like to make a
short statement please five minutes
thank you chair it'll become apparent
why I didn't want to actually uh make
this statement during the uh the debate
um we had a planning application come to
us something a while ago where I in
reading it I
found that the s106 agreement monies
that were actually recommended for it
were for the education side of things
were noted as not needed because there
was capacity
unfortunately there is a situation where
special needs Schools fall through the
gap
s106 agreement monies can only be
allocated from proposals that come
through Council for schools and
education within the area that we are
actually
responsible for
the problem with that is that special
needs schools are more more often than
not not within the area that we are
actually
um in charge of
problem with that is that what we have
in Essex we have a a situation at the
moment where there is massive over
capacity in um in Special Needs schools
and there is a huge need for more places
in
um in these Special Needs schools I'm
bringing this to the notice of members
because it's something that came to me
and I wasn't aware of but a lot of
special needs schools in Essex are
anything up to about 125 over subscribed
and their their Finance is limited
because it does not get allocated from
local funds where they the local is
actually
um uh providing no assistance to these
actual schools so I just wanted to bring
that to the notice of the members
because it was new to me and if we did
an opportunity to actually support a
school like we've been talking about
tonight then I would encourage members
to uh to offer their support that why I
did not want to actually say within the
debate thank you very much thank you
councilories members will go on to item
seven
the finchfield trust
um 22 stroke zero zero six six zero four
to four
and again Katie it's over to you please
thank you chairman
uh finchfield is a small cul-de-sac
located off Eastwood Road I have some
aerial photographs on the screen to
provide some context within the wider
area so you can see finchville's just so
located to the South and then you have
Eastwood Road here and then King
George's Park just further north and
then the main High Street just over here
um if I scroll down actually I think
I've gotten more zoomed in photo here we
go so the application site is located at
the end of end of Finch field and is
fronted by numbers seven to twelve so as
from the aerial photograph again you can
see this is the application site here
and you have finchfields Road here with
the Bungalows fronting it
the finchfield residents qualify to live
in these properties either due to
infirmities or by virtue of being 65
years of age or above I know they are
managed by the finchville trust and
vulture District Council
and the application site is
characterized as a soft landscaped a
mainity area and each dwelling benefits
from a soft landscape Frontage and this
can be seen again from this aerial
photograph where you can see very much
green spaces to the front of each
dwelling as well as the amenity areas
subject to the application
however it is clear from historic aerial
photographs of the site that has been
used informally for parking due to Mint
Fields being able to accommodate parking
elsewhere so this Photograph on the
screen now is from 2017 and you can see
although let me zoom in a bit actually
hopefully you can now see that there is
a car parked informally on the verge
here and then also a van parked
um on the application site if I just go
to my site photos
there is a sign currently on the grass
informing residents to not park there
due to the ongoing issue of this and the
road itself I'll just scroll down again
it's
um you can kind of see in this
Photograph it's too narrow for a car to
be parked on the road and a car to
really pass by as well so
um that's lead led to some highway
safety issues
uh planning permission is now sought for
the change of use of the soft landscape
amenity area to create five parking
spaces
the parking spaces would allow for
finches residents visitors to park
short-term clear of the highway
scheme has included a landscaping
provision around the period perimeter of
the parking spaces and would utilize an
existing drop card which would be made
good the parking spaces would be
finished with Marshall's grass guard
power mobile block Paving and plotting
as proposed around the parking area so
um this Photograph up here just
demonstrates what the grass guard would
be so it's kind of this block Paving
that allows for the grass to grow
through so you still have the appearance
of the grass area but without it kind of
facing the wear and tear of um without
the block Paving as well and then around
the outskirts of the parking spaces you
see this planting and that varies in
species and that's specified both within
the report and on the plan
the Preamble for sbd2 discusses that
grass verges and open amenity areas were
usually intended to be an integral part
of estate design and layout
looking at the layout of Finch Fields it
is assumed that the amenity area was
designed to soften the erection of the
bungalows
whilst local policy seeks to avoid the
loss of open amenity areas there is
particular resistance to the enclosure
of land into private Gardens whereas the
proposed development would not enclose
the site and would maintain it as open
space
the planting and materials proposed
would take on an appearance that would
be sympathetic with the soft landscaped
character of Finch fields as the garden
areas are the dwellings along Finch
roads for the most part are in excess of
the requirement outlined in sbd2 it is
considered that the amenity space was
not intended to form additional Gardens
but rather for the visual Aesthetics of
the estate
it is considered that development has
been that the development has been
designed in a manner which would be
sympathetic to the charactered area and
the development would comply with the
objectives of national and local policy
and guidance
the post development would introduce car
parking where it is currently absent
although there would be a degree of
noise resulting from the development the
highway extends up to the existing
amenity area and is in close enough
proximity to result in some levels of
noise in addition the parking area would
be for use by visitors and cars would
not continuously be used in this area
throughout the day and night no labor
objections have been received and it is
considered unlikely that the level of
noise that would result would be
unreasonable as such the proposal is
considered compliant with policy dm1
the proposed development would introduce
five visitor parking spaces and I'll
just zoom in so you can see those
demarcated a little clearer
the parking spaces would meet the
minimum Dimensions stipulated by the
Apollo parking standards and they've
also included the six meter line behind
the parking spaces to demonstrate that
they would be able to reverse out easily
from the spaces to exit the site forward
finchfield is a narrow road which would
not have a great enough width to
accommodate traffic passing by parked
cars there is also restriction from
parking on the road Monday to Saturday
from 8 A.M to 6PM therefore visitors
have to park in nearby pan display car
parks
as the development would introduced
visited parking where there is currently
no formal parking the development would
be an improvement from the current
parking provision on site the existing
dropped curve would be suitably altered
to become a vehicular access
County Council as the local Highway
Authority have been consulted in the
application and have raised no objection
at present four residents have cars and
either use the nearby public car Parks
or have other private Arrangements off
Street the applicant has expressed that
the residents are clear that the parking
would be primarily for visitors and
residents would be stripped to park in
the Bays for a limited time period only
the applicant has advised that signage
would be erected to instruct on this
it is considered that the proposal would
improve the highway safety of Finch
fields and would therefore be acceptable
in regards to the mppf and policy dm30
the application is recommended for
approval chairman subject to the
conditions set out in the report thank
you thank you very much we have one wool
member here uh councilor Jack Gilman
thank you chairman
um I'll state from the outset that I do
do agree with the need for parking in
this area I do have concerns though that
because I'm familiar with some of the
people that live around that area is
that we talk about visitors and I know
that they would like obviously disabled
Bay and so on and one of the big issues
there for their age and illnesses Etc is
care workers who have nowhere to come
when they come and visit patients Etc
and it also leads down to understand to
Britain's court and we have a little bit
of a conflict sometime with parking over
there so my question if I may although
I'm in favor of this particular
application my question is if I might is
are we going to maintain control of that
parking area and so if we get some Brave
ignorant person who wants to leave their
vehicles there and move it out of Castle
Castle Road car park what what we're
going to do about these people I mean I
know you've said that it's only going to
be for visitors temporary parking but
there's always going to someone who's
going to test the water so what I want
to know is what will we do about that
thank you
so
inflation I did speak to our asset
management team about this because I
knew that there would be concerns they
haven't they did discuss that there
would be the signage and I believe it
would be the council enforcing that but
it is largely outside of the
consideration of planning and that we've
been covered by elsewhere
yes councilor yeah thank you chairman
it's only that I mentioned that because
technically it comes under a trust
doesn't it the finch field is a trust
although but albeit the council is part
of that crash but so is there a way we
can go back to the trust for the trust
of some area enforce this or something
I'm not I'm not on the legal side I
don't know so
I don't well we would really need
a mind assigning would be that it
wouldn't be for the trust to enforce
that they're kind of the management of
the
Bungalows and the residents in it but it
would be down to the council to enforce
any parking regulation in that area
before I bring in councilor Stanley I
just would like to ask one question
um this isn't planning
um I did mention it to you the other day
regarding the work that's going to be
done for the parking could we ask the
um applicant to actually send letters to
this Bungalow so they are aware and if
they're not really aware their families
will be aware of what's actually going
on and I know this isn't a planning it's
just a consideration to the
residents who live there the asset team
did inform me that they will be sending
letters oh thank you very much right
sorry to butt in there um councilor
Stanley
foreign
thank you chairman
um
whilst I agree that there is a parking
problem around there could I put have a
couple of conditions put on that area
one is that uh a barrier a metal barrier
a railing of some sorts would be
advisable for that area as
if somebody puts their foot on the
accelerator instead of the brake and we
already know that the area is has got
some elderly people in and any park in
there if they put their foot on the
accelerator they'll go straight into the
Bungalows adjacent to that parking area
so be careful it's the only um elderly
people that do that yeah
can you just modify that to say sorry
visitors visitors thank you sorry
visitors that may be
parking in that area may put on the the
wrong foot on the wrong pedal so there
needs to be a barrier of some
description there and whilst the I agree
with the greenery I'm ever so pleased
that the greenery is there but could we
have a couple of trees put in please
as this would because I read the reason
that I say this is that
trees are very good for grabbing carbon
and if people have got cars there's
going to be carbon coming out and we
need to show that we are in a carbon
neutral zone so I think trees would be
admirable say two or three trees perhaps
across the back
which would which would look quite
attractive if that's possible please
um sorry yeah yeah thank you so
um
I I think what we could do is probably
put a condition on asking for an amended
Landscaping scheme so at the moment
there is a condition that the
development has to be carried out with
the Landscaping provision submitted but
what we can do is put a separate one on
and request additional details
um and that could we could specify that
it needed to include some sort of low
barrier or fencing I think perhaps I
would be more favorable to a wooden
fence or barrier as opposed to a metal
one because I think that would look a
bit unattractive with the soft
Landscaping but it would still have the
impact of
um I would I hope that it would stop
somebody
um driving forward but um we can put a
condition on requiring additional
Landscaping
yeah I wouldn't consider a piece of wood
to stop a car would you but hey if if
that is the case then that is the case
but I think uh you know we need to put a
bit of a safety feature in there because
because of such happenings could happen
and we I wouldn't want to see anybody
end up in somebody's front room I don't
know that do you but we could ask as
Casey said they could go back and ask
for that yeah okay thank you are there
any other members wishing to speak oh
cancer Crips counselor Constable take
your turn whichever just a quickie all
right
glad to see parking being added in as
opposed to our normal routine on new
developments with not meeting the
parking requirements so it's a positive
for you thank you very much councilor
constable
foreign
is for over a certain age group and at
the moment a lot of the residents are
probably in firm and maybe not driving
and having carers but as those residents
pass on and younger people come in and
they will have probably have cars
there's no residence parking there and I
think that's probably a greater concern
than visitors parking
Casey please
thank you too
um I think the point of it the purpose
of these Bungalows is to serve a certain
group of people and although at present
though that group of people that are in
the Bungalows do not have cars
it isn't part of this application that
we are considering the residence parking
so the Bungalows already exist and
that's been that has been approved
in the 20th century with no parking and
as a discussed there are kind of
informal Arrangements uh with the church
and other public car parks for the
residents to be observed by permits and
to park their cars that way so
um I appreciate what you're saying about
the rest of the parking beer isn't part
and parcel of this application what
we've got to consider is what's in front
of us and that is visited parking
um and until there was kind of evidence
in front of us that there is a strain
and that application is brought forward
that that would be the time for that to
be considered and the moment we've got
to consider visited parking and it would
improve a situation on the site
um we as I've shown in the photographs
there is
a highway safety issue where cars are
parked miscellaneously on the on the
road and causing issues so although it
wouldn't necessarily tackle all issues
to do with parking it would be an
improvement over what's existing at the
moment
thank you thank you
well I'm going to bring this to an end
in a minute because I think we've
discussed this Council Williams
because we're only deciding about the
visiting car Parks not about the that's
what this is the application is
the car parking spaces I appreciate that
um
I presume that none of these these
homes have a driveway next to them and
so therefore they wouldn't be able to
use electric car charging so perhaps we
could ask that a couple of them have
electric or charging points
foreign
yeah we don't currently have local
policy or national guidance which really
drives EV charging points for this scale
of development
um and where they is for visitors and
they will only be there short time it
would primarily be for people kind of
finish visit their friends and family
and also care workers deliveries things
like that I'm not sure that there would
be long enough to charge the vehicles
but there are also public car parks
nearby that there are EV charging points
provided
um hopefully that answers it okay thank
you hold on I've got
cancel the mill and then who else was
over this side councilor Foster and then
I'm gonna the last question is going to
be councilorman because this is all
we're discussing is the visitors car
parking not the development as a whole
all right that's exactly what I'm going
to mention
um when I was with the the trustees and
we're looking at this this provides a
kind of grass Crete surface whereas at
the moment it's mud you know we can be
mud if it's heavy rain and of course if
we get Emergency Services vehicles our
ambulance is coming in this is very
useful facility so as it is it's a
sensible thing to do and I I support it
and that's one big advantage of this and
when carers arrive in vehicles or they
get mini buses coming to pick up
residents and so on it's absolutely
ideal thank you very much for counselor
um thank you chairman just quickly as a
possibility for Council to stand his
concern and raise curb and may I move
for approval
thank you have we got a second Dove for
the motion oh we've got loads of them
take your pick whichever you would like
to do
right so we've got members who've got a
motion
um on the table for approval a second
did by who have you taken
that's the Lawman members can I have a
vote show of hands
a few things
well things we didn't have any motion oh
the only conditions now the only
condition we've had not emotion is a
condition that Casey's going to go back
and see about a barrier
Iron Man soft Landscaping where
conditional Landscaping yeah the
landscape members
I am now members can I have a show of
hands for approval please
that is unanimous thank you members I'm
going to close the meeting at or by my
watch it's ten to nine
uh I haven't got anything slightly any
other minutes because I've just got two
little hands thank you for members for a
very good meeting see you at the next
one well I might not it might not be me